>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Teresa Sierra: Good
morning, everybody.
Hi. My name is Teresa Sierra.
I'm the chief of the [inaudible]
government [inaudible] division
that's sponsoring this program.
And it is my great pleasure to
introduce to you a real good friend
of our division and of the library.
Professor Joe Campbell.
He has been here before.
He's a regular coming to our
reading room at least twice a year.
We see him sauntering in followed
by a bunch of his students,
and he's introducing these students
to primary sources,
namely newspapers.
He's become an expert, if
you guys need help out there,
with the scan view
microfilm readers.
That's your guy.
Anyway, seriously he has
a PhD from North Carolina.
Right? Am I right?
He's a tenured professor
at American University.
He has written numerous
books, articles.
I've seen him on TV
a number of times
where he makes appearances
on a regular basis.
I was talking to somebody
this afternoon --
this morning about one
of the books he wrote
that I found very intriguing.
It's called "1995:
The Watershed Year."
Did I say that right?
Okay. And why is 1995 all that
important, you might wonder.
Well, Professor Campbell
has an idea.
That was the year of the
Oklahoma City bombing,
the trial of the century
[inaudible] in Florida.
Monica Lewinsky.
Anybody remember that?
And the launching of the internet.
So he has something going on there.
But I won't bore you with all my
great interest in what he writes
and how he approaches
his teaching career.
He has received many awards
and I think perhaps --
Maybe I'm wrong, and maybe
he'll tell me someday.
His greatest award that he
treasures the most is the year
that he was named faculty
member of the year
by the student body of
American University.
So it's a great honor.
So why don't you help me bring him
to the podium, give
him a warm welcome?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Campbell: Thank you.
Terri, thanks very much.
That was a great introduction.
In 1995 I -- The subtitle was "The
Year the Future Began," but I kind
of like yours a little better.
It's -- The watershed year.
And what? What did we say?
The internet, Oklahoma
City, the bombing there,
the O.J. Simpson Trial of the
Century, Clinton meets Lewinsky
and begins the dalliance
that led to his impeachment.
And also the Dayton
Peace Accords in 1995
that ended the long war in Bosnia.
And it was really a moment in which
the United States found itself
at the peak of its post war power
as the unrivaled superpower.
It was able to bring an end to this
long and bloody conflict in Bosnia.
So yes. Those are the
respective chapters of "1995:
The Year the Future Began."
But that was a book that
came out two years ago.
Today we're talking about --
Related to a book that came out,
a second edition that came out,
just about a year ago titled
"Getting it Wrong:
Debunking the Greatest Myths
in American Journalism."
And it takes a look at media driven
myths which are prominent stories
about and/or by the news
media that are widely believed
and often retold, but which under
close inspection, under scrutiny,
dissolve as apocryphal or wildly
exaggerated media driven myths.
And they so happen to be fairly
close cousins to fake news.
You can think of media myth as
prominent cases of fake news
that have masqueraded as
factual for many, many years.
So that will be the
essence of the talk today.
I look forward to engaging you all
with some questions and answers
and comments during the Q and
A section that will follow.
But first let me say it's a
terrific pleasure to be back
at the Library of Congress.
I have, as Terri was suggesting,
done a lot of my research
at the Library of Congress
over the years.
And what better way to do
it than reading microfilm,
squinting in to the
microfilm reader?
And I can't say that I am up
to speed on the view scans.
I do get training every
once in a while on that,
and then I completely
forget about it and I'm back
on the old crank machines, you know.
Which I love, and I've done
a good deal of my research
over the past 20 years here
at the Library of Congress.
So it's really a pleasure
to be back,
to be invited back, to give a talk.
And to talk about some
of my research.
And not only do I do a lot
of research here, but
many of my students.
I bring students to the Library
of Congress, and over the years --
I've been [inaudible]
about 20 years.
And over those years hundreds
of my students, undergrad
and grad students, have come
to the Library of Congress
and have come mostly
for the newspaper
and current periodical
reading room to do research
on research related
assignments in my classes.
And they have, without
exception, enjoyed the experience.
For undergrads especially it
is kind of cool for them to say
that they've been able to do
research at the Library of Congress.
This fantastic only in
Washington institution.
And for the students studying in
D.C., this is a must do to come
to the Library of Congress.
Not to get the reader's
card and take a tour,
but to actually do research,
to crank the microfilm.
Here's a couple of
students doing just that.
So my thanks again to Terri
and Georgia [inaudible]
and their colleagues for
the invitation today.
It is an opportunity to talk
about some of my research,
and also to explore with you
some of the recent developments
in what is known as fake news.
Fake news.
Now, believe it or not,
there are people who think
that fake news is not really
all that big of a problem.
And there was a fair amount of
discussion earlier this year
in journalism reviews and
journalism periodicals
about whether this is serious enough
to really merit a lot of attention.
The thinking was, "Well, fake
news is kind of ephemeral."
It appears on these
way out there websites,
and it's really not getting
all that many eyeballs compared
to mainstream media outlets.
Both traditional and online.
So there's this thinking that
maybe we're overstating fake news,
especially the effects of fake news,
that maybe it's not as important
or as decisive as some people
have tried to make it out to be.
That it really may not be
such a problem after all.
But then again you
might want to tell
that to [inaudible] the pizzeria
on Connecticut Avenue that had --
These episodes of fake news
are so bizarre, but this one,
as you probably remember, was
the site of an encounter back
in December in which a guy, a
28 year old from North Carolina,
drove up to the restaurant and
to investigate, as he said.
To self investigate reports
that the pizzeria was being used
by Hillary Clinton and her campaign
manager to run a child sex ring
in the back rooms and
in the basement.
I mean it's just a bizarre store.
It's not even close to being
plausible, but nonetheless it was
out there in these --
the Netherland, the
netherworld of the internet.
And this was an example of fake
news that really went viral.
And this episode in which a
guy from North Carolina came
up to self investigate,
and he discharged a firearm
inside the restaurant,
you know causing a complete
shutdown of that restaurant as well
as restaurants and
businesses nearby.
It was a serious, serious problem.
And the story continues to circulate
even though it's been widely
debunked, routinely
rejected as implausible.
But it exists, and it's out there,
and it continues to circulate.
So it is an example of fake
news being a serious problem
or turning into a serious problem.
And then just the other day, just
the other day, we were reminded
of the reach of fake news as this
"New York Times" article reports
Google and Facebook feeds,
newsfeeds from those
two platforms, were --
Recipients were receiving
word that the shooter
at the Las Vegas casino was a
liberal, was a fan of Rachel Maddow,
not a fan of Donald Trump,
supported by MoveOn.org,
and that he had been
linked to the Islamic state.
All of which was untrue.
None of this stuff is accurate, but
it was out there and had been passed
on through the algorithms of
Facebook and Google to many,
many unsuspecting recipients
of these platforms.
And Facebook has other problems,
as you no doubt have been aware.
I mean it's not just
a fake news problem,
but fake ads have circulated on
Facebook, including those linked
to accounts linked to Russia
over the past several months during
the presidential campaign last year
and in to this year as well.
So Facebook and Google in
particular have problems in terms
of letting algorithms
drive their content,
what appears on their
platforms, on their newsfeeds.
And this is no minor issue.
This is no minor problem.
And it's hard to see how Facebook
and Google can let this go
on without -- by just allowing
algorithms to drive content.
And that's essentially
where we are now.
So anything, almost anything, wild
stuff, phony ads, can get up there
and reach incredible
numbers of people.
Because these platforms, two-thirds
of American adults every day log
in to social media of one
kind or another for news.
So this is a serious issue in terms
of undercutting popular discourse.
One thing I will say
about fake news, though.
It's not new.
We have dealt with fake
news for many years.
Perhaps not with the intensity
that algorithms transmit news
to newsfeeds at Facebook and Google,
but nonetheless it
has been out there.
It has circulated.
For example, the "New
York Sun" in August
of 1835 published a six part
series in which it reported,
this penny newspaper
in New York City --
reported that there was
life found on the moon.
And that the lunar landscape was
populated by exotic animals as well
as bat wing humanoid characters.
The "New York Sun's"
ostensible source
for this reporting was the work of
an astronomer named John Herschel
who was reporting from the southern
hemisphere that had been able
to see these objects
on the lunar surface.
Even to the degree of being
able to determine the gender
of these winged humanoid figures.
The "New York Sun," 1835.
Later in the 19th century in 1897 a
"New York Herald" reporter named
George Bronson Rea published a book
called "Facts and Fakes About Cuba."
"Facts and Fakes About Cuba."
And he was lamenting, this reporter,
he was lamenting the circulation
of fakes, fake news, about the
Cuban insurrection that led in 1898
to the Spanish American War.
And he was complaining and laid
out his case in a book that came
out in early 1897 about
the correspondence
for New York newspapers
as well as others who were
out there peddling this
garbage, this made up stuff,
these extreme stories about
Spanish atrocities on Cuba.
Intended, he thought, to whip
up public sentiment at home
in the United States to
support U.S. intervention
in the war for Cuban independence.
That's what happened, but not
because of news content necessarily.
It's because of other
factors that diplomatic clash
between the United States, Cuba,
and Spain, the colonial rulers,
and that's what led in
1898, April of 1898,
to the Spanish American War.
But the point here is that fakes
and facts had been long disputed,
and had been long a subject
in American journalism.
Now one problem with fake news
in the contemporary context
is what do we mean by this.
What do we mean?
It's a term that's proven
very flexible, very fluid.
In fact, so fluid that the
"Washington Post's" media
writer Margaret Sullivan came
out earlier this year and said, "You
know, this term ought to be banned
because we can't make
any sense out of it."
It's been corrupted.
It's been appropriated.
Yeah. It's been appropriated by
the president of the United States
who routinely invokes the term
fake news to criticize and comment
on anything that he doesn't
think is entirely accurate
or at least does not
put his administration
and his policies in the best light.
Fake news, he calls them.
Now Trump, of course, as we know,
has been one of the purveyors
of fake news for many
months, if not years.
He was an advocate of the
Birther interpretation
of Barack Obama's birthplace.
He was -- Oh yeah.
He was also one of the -- During
the primary campaign last year
in 2016 he accused Ted Cruz's
father of being complicit
in the JFK assassination.
Something he picked up presumably
from the "National Enquirer"
or something akin to that.
But Trump has been out
there even from his --
The day he took office
he was saying, "You know,
that crowd out there was the biggest
crowd ever for an inauguration.
More people saw my
inauguration than anybody else's."
You know, demonstrable not true.
I mean a lot of photographs
suggested that, you know,
there was a pretty thin turnout
in the streets of Washington
for Trump's inauguration.
But nonetheless it just
is emblematic of his use
of exaggeration, hyperbole,
falsehoods,
to push an agenda, I suppose.
His own agenda.
He's very narcissistic.
Anyway, he has made
great use of fake news,
and is one of the reasons why the
"Washington Post" suggested
we bury this term.
But it's out there.
And again the definitions are
very difficult to pin down.
The online site Vox says that
false news -- Defines it this way.
False news claims are presented
in an official looking way,
often online, and in a way to --
that's intended to deceive
readers, intended to deceive.
The "Post" has said
it defined fake news
as deliberately constructed lies
in the form of news articles
that are meant to mislead
the public.
So you see both of these definitions
include a sense of intention.
Intentionality.
Now I would offer a definition
that sort of takes us away
from intentionality and just
embraces everything that is false,
erroneous, dubious, media driven
tales that circulate widely
and serve to corrupt or
warp popular discourse.
And, as we can see from the
examples I mentioned earlier,
that's exactly what fake news does.
It corrupts and warps
popular discourse.
Now my definition has
these advantages.
It removes intent which can
be very difficult to prove.
How do you know what's
going on inside the mind
of somebody who's intentionally
or not putting
out erroneous information?
So we just get rid of intent.
It also recognizes that there
is this potential warping
or corrupting effect of fake news.
A serious problem, in my view.
And thirdly, this definition insists
that this is not just
a social media problem.
This is not just a
problem of the internet
and its far out there fringes.
This also includes mainstream media.
It is far more than just -- Fake
news is far more than just postings
at obscure websites on the
fringes of the online world.
In fact, the news media these days
are widely distrusted for an ability
to present news in a fair
minded and accurate fashion.
And you can see from this
chart these are Gallup polls
that go back 40 plus years.
And what is shown here goes back
about 20 showing how popular
recognition of the trust
in the media has subsided,
has eased down,
has ebbed consistently
since the late 1990s.
And has reached a low during the
presidential campaign of 2016.
Less than one-third of
American adults responding
to the survey found
that the news media --
They could have a great deal
or a fair amount of trust
in what the news media
were reporting.
So I submit that fake news
includes, and should include --
A discussion of fake news should
include mainstream news media
as well.
And the media do have a
trust problem, as we can see.
And there are a number of examples
of mainstream media putting
out stories that had to be retracted
or walked back or modified.
These are dubious tales that
corrupt the popular discourse.
And would meet my definition
of fake news.
The first one there is from the
"Washington Post" in which the
"Post" reported that a Russia
linked operation had hacked
in to the U.S. electrical grid
through a utility in Vermont.
Serious stuff.
The Russians are tapping
in to the electrical grid.
You know, there's potential
problems ahead.
The story turned out to be
considerably less than that.
There was one laptop at a Vermont
utility that had some malware
that was like that used by
some Russian hackers that may
or may not have been
connected to the grid.
In fact, the Vermont
utility said it hadn't been.
So there's -- From this one case of
malware on a laptop the "Post" blew
up the story to Russian
intervention, Russian hacking
in to the U.S. electrical grid.
That's kind of fake news.
Another one that got
wide attention right
after Trump's inauguration was the
"Time Magazine" report that Trump
or his aides had removed the bust
of the Reverend Martin Luther
King Junior from the Oval Office.
"Time" put this out there.
It was a pool report, and the
"Time" reporter was the
pool reporter of that time.
Reported it apparently without
checking or asking or looking
around and had to retract it.
But this story is often
invoked by conservative critics
of the news media as an example
of the media getting it wrong.
Putting out fake news.
And then, of course, there
was the case this summer
in which three top
level CNN staffers,
including a Pulitzer Prize winner
for the "New York Times" had
to resign because of a story linking
Scaramucci, a Trump associate later,
for what, 10 days, a
Trump White House staffer,
to a Russian investment house.
A story that CNN put out
there, posted online,
on the basis of a single
anonymous source.
One anonymous source.
And retracted the story.
And forced the three
staffers to resign.
The exact details of what
went on in that case,
and why the story was
totally erroneous
or poorly reported has
never really been disclosed.
There's still questions about why
they took the steps that they did.
But nonetheless this is an
example of a story that was
out there supported by an
investigative team at CNN
that later blew up in its face.
And, you know, I'm thinking that
maybe these examples are not all
that surprising because some
of the best known stories
that journalists tell
about themselves
and about their profession
are themselves exaggerated.
Mythical. They're media myths.
And among them is the
tale of Watergate.
Watergate.
That the dogged reporters of Bob
Woodward and Carl Bernstein for the
"Washington Post" uncovered the
evidence that forced Richard Nixon
to resign the presidency.
This is the dominant
narrative of Watergate.
You find this everywhere.
It's in journalism textbooks.
It's in the popular media.
It's a shorthand version of
what this scandal was all about.
And it is derived from
in part Woodward
and Bernstein's very
successful book that came
out just months before Richard
Nixon resigned in August of '74.
Based also on the very
successful film
that they -- based on their book.
Same title.
"All the President's Men"
that came out in 1976.
And also based on the 20 or
so year long guessing game,
more like 30 year guessing
game, about the identity
of the super secret source
that Woodward had whom was
identified only in the book
and movie as Deep Throat.
Turned out to be Mark Felt, number
two at the FBI, who was the subject
of a movie now that's just out
these days called "Mark Felt:
The Man Who Took Down
the White House."
The reviews have been
pretty terrible,
but I still plan to see it.
In any event, it's not as good, I
guess, as "All the President's Men,"
the movie version or
the cinematic version
of "All the President's Men."
It's interesting that even
at the "Post" the principles
on the news side of the "Post"
over the years have
rejected this interpretation,
this heroic journalist
narrative of Watergate.
They've scoffed at it.
Katharine Graham who was the
publisher before, during,
and after the Watergate period
said at the 25th anniversary
of the break in, the seminal
crime of the Watergate scandal,
a break in at Democratic National
Headquarters, in June of 1972.
She said at the 25th anniversary of
this, "Sometimes people accuse us
of bringing down a president,
which of course we did not do."
The processes that caused
Richard Nixon's resignation
were constitutional.
And she's not alone.
Ben Bradley, the executive
editor of the "Post" at the time,
shown here on your right,
said about the same time
that it must be remembered
that Nixon got Nixon.
It wasn't the "Post" that got Nixon.
And he's referring here to
the secret White House tapes
that Richard Nixon made of most
conversations in the Oval Office
between 1971 and '73, tapes that
captured him approving a plan
to divert the investigation
in to the Watergate break in.
Clear obstruction of
justice that led
to his resignation
in August of 1974.
Nixon got Nixon.
The "Post" didn't get Nixon.
According to Ben Bradley.
And Bob Woodward, in Earth year
terms, has said somewhat the same.
"To say that the press brought
down Nixon, that's horse poop."
I think that's what those are for.
Anyway, he is -- He
too has been adamant
about this heroic journalist
interpretation being a wrong headed
interpretation of Watergate.
And I think the ombudsman
for the "Post" back at the 10
or 12 years ago, a great guy by
the name of Michael Getler --
He was ombudsman after that
for PBS for a number of years.
Getler captured it correctly,
that it was not the "Post,"
but it was the FBI [inaudible]
acting in bipartisan fashion,
and the courts, that brought down
the Richard Nixon administration.
It wasn't the "Post."
And I think that was quite right.
Because to roll up a
scandal of the dimensions
of Watergate required
the collective,
if not always the coordinated
efforts, of many forces
and factors including special
prosecutors, federal judges,
both houses of Congress, the Supreme
Court, Justice Department, and FBI.
And even then, even then
with all these forces arrayed
against Richard Nixon,
he would have walked,
he would have survived
the Watergate scandal,
had it not been for those tapes.
Had it not been for
the clear cut evidence
that showed Nixon was culpable
of obstructing justice.
It needed that kind
of certain evidence
to dynamite the president
from the Oval Office.
He resigned in August of '74 before
he could be impeached and convicted.
He certainly would have been both.
So why does this interpretation,
this media myth
of the heroic journalist,
why does this live on?
Why does this persist?
Why is it the dominant narrative?
At least three reasons.
It's convenient shorthand
for explaining the
Watergate scandal nowadays.
It's been 45 years
since the burglary
at the Democratic National
Headquarters, and there's been a lot
that happened during those 2 and a
half years of the Watergate period.
Who was doing what, and
where, and who was Haldeman,
who was Mitchell, who
were all these guys?
It's -- It was hard to keep
it straight at the time.
It's impossible to keep
it straight these days.
So what we have as the dominant
narrative is a simplified easily
accessible shorthand that explains
Watergate, that embraces the essence
of the scandal, I.E.
Richard Nixon resigned,
but adds a little media
centric window dressing to it.
That it was because of these
dogged intrepid reporters
that Richard Nixon lost his office.
Easy to explain.
It's convenient.
It's simplistic.
It avoids the complexities
of what was a very
sprawling and complex scandal.
And it's also very
reassuring to journalists.
It lives on because
it's a reassuring tale.
It's an affirmation tale that
journalists can make a difference,
that they can be decisive forces
and factors in the greater scheme
of things in American politics.
It's a media centric interpretation,
but it's also one that's
reassuring to journalists.
Let's move on to another more
recent, if you will, media myth.
That of the coverage of Hurricane
Katrina 12 years ago, 2005.
The media themselves patted
themselves on the back saying,
"This was a triumph,
a media triumph."
I call it the myth of
superlative reporting.
There was a lot of self referential
praise in the immediate aftermath
of the hurricane's passage.
It made landfall just east of
New Orleans, and in the aftermath
of the hurricane's passage the dikes
protecting the city were breached,
flooding much of New Orleans.
In the aftermath the likes of
Dan Rather were very extravagant
in saying that this was
a high heroic moment
in American journalism.
He called it one of the
quintessential great moments
in television news
ranking, right up there
with the Nixon/Kennedy debates,
the Kennedy assassination,
the Watergate coverage, you name it.
It was a landmark, Dan Rather said.
And the media narrative about
Hurricane Katrina was much
like that, that this
was a memorable moment
in which the media found their voice
and were able to confront and stand
up to public officials,
local, state, and federal,
holding them accountable for what
was a pretty muddled response.
Especially by federal and local
authorities in New Orleans
in the aftermath of the hurricane.
The reality, though,
was quite different.
The reality of the
reporting was quite different.
There was no high heroic
moment in American journalism.
And in important respects
the coverage
of Hurricane Katrina's aftermath
was badly flawed and exaggerated.
They got it wrong.
Crucial details.
Journalists were in error.
They described scenes of apocalyptic
horror and mayhem, and lawlessness
that the storm supposedly had
unleashed across New Orleans.
They told of snipers
firing at medical personnel,
snipers firing at helicopters.
They told of bodies being stacked
up like cordwood in the Superdome
and convention center
where people sought refuge
from the storm's after effects.
They talked about roving
gangs preying on tourists,
terrorizing people who took
refuge in the Superdome.
They said children were the
victims of sexual assault,
how one seven-year-old was raped
and had her throat slashed.
They also spoke about other horrors.
Sharks plying the flood
waters of New Orleans.
Things like that.
This was a U.S. and an
international media response.
International media,
particularly the British media,
just loved this story about
the apocalypse of New Orleans.
This was a moment in which
the United States was going
to -- being brought down.
And the British national
media just ate it up.
But so did the U.S. news media.
The media narrative, the dominant
media narrative, was of chaos,
anarchy, mayhem, and few, if
any, of these horrific accounts
of lawlessness, anarchy,
and the aftermath
of Hurricane Katrina's
passage were true.
Some reporting of that
afterwards found
that almost all these stories
were based largely on rumor,
were exaggerated, and untrue.
The effects were to paint
for America and the rest
of the world scenes of
unimaginable horror.
And they had the effect of
defaming a city and its people
at a time of their greatest need.
And these misreported stories
about anarchy and chaos and mayhem
in New Orleans also had the
effect of slowing the arrival
of federal aid and
assistance to New Orleans.
The deployment of aid was slowed
down because the situation seemed
so untenable that you could
not put people in there
until you were certain that
everything was under control.
These news reports in the first days
after Hurricane Katrina's
passage made it clear
that the situation
was not under control.
In fact, it was one
of mayhem and chaos.
As I say, that was untrue.
It was largely debunked.
In fact, a bipartisan congressional
committee looking in to the response
to Hurricane Katrina touched
on the media's coverage too.
It came to the conclusion that
if anyone rioted in the aftermath
of Hurricane Katrina,
it was the media.
But, as I say, chaos
was the media narrative.
And I believe we have some front
pages on the display table there
that suggest as much, including
the one that is on your far right
from the "Times-Picayune,"
the New Orleans newspaper.
"Help Us Please."
The subheading read,
"After the Disaster Chaos
and Lawlessness Ruled the Streets."
And that, as I say, was the
dominant media narrative.
So I think it's important to
keep in mind that early accounts
of disasters often are in error.
Not always, but they often are.
Hurricane Katrina was
one of those cases.
And it's also I think
useful to keep in mind
that mainstream media are not
always going to get it right.
They're not always
going to get it right.
So, with that in mind, I'd
like to offer a few practical
straightforward suggestions
that may be useful in
combating fake news.
From whatever the source.
My first suggestion --
There are five of them.
My first suggestion was that
one about the mainstream media.
They can get it wrong in the
early reporting about disasters.
My second suggestion is develop
an ability to take the sniff test.
The sniff test, it's akin to when
you open the refrigerator door
and the milk has gone bad.
You know, you know it.
And it's like that
with news stories.
If something just doesn't seem quite
right, if it smells a little off,
then maybe you should treat it
as something that's
maybe not quite accurate.
Like the shooter in Las Vegas.
I mean those early reports
that appeared on Facebook
and Google were probably a little
too exaggerated to be true.
To pass the sniff test.
Be wary of sources of stories
that rely exclusively
on anonymous sources.
One of my favorite examples of that
is the "Washington Post's" report
in early April 2003
about Jessica Lynch,
a young 19 year old waif-like army
supply clerk from West Virginia
who signed up for the army to be
able to use the benefits later
on to go to college
and get a degree.
She was in a supply unit.
She was in a maintenance company.
Never expected to see
combat in Iraq.
But because of a wrong turn that
her unit took in the early days
of the Iraq war, right after the
invasion began in March of 2003,
Jessica Lynch's unit came
under ambush in the city
of Nasiriyah in southern Iraq.
And the unit was badly shot up.
11 people were killed in the unit.
Several were taken prisoner,
among them Jessica Lynch.
She was badly injured and was
rescued by a special operations unit
on the first of April, 2003.
It was the first time
that an American prisoner
of war had been rescued from
behind enemy lines during
combat operations.
The first time since World War II.
Two days after the rescue the
"Washington Post" reports
this story on the front page.
That she was fighting to the death.
Based on two anonymous sources.
And the "Post" has
never identified them.
Jessica Lynch was reported to
be fighting like a female Rambo,
taking on the -- Attacking
Iraqis, firing her weapon
until she ran out of ammunition.
She kept the Iraqis at bay despite
herself being shot and stabbed
and seeing colleagues
fall all around her.
It was an electrifying story.
It was a story that was picked up by
news organizations around the world.
It was a story that was
irresistibly good in a lot of ways.
It was based on two
anonymous sources.
Neither of the "Post"
reporters whose bylines appeared
on that story were
in Iraq at the time.
They reported the story
from Washington.
The story turned out to be
wrong in all important respects.
Jessica Lynch was in Iraq.
She was in Nasiriyah with her unit.
She did not fire a
shot during the ambush.
Her gun jammed.
And she was in the
backseat of a Humvee
as it tried to escape the ambush.
And she, as the Humvee was trying
to make its escape from the city --
She was in the backseat
with her head
down between her knees
saying, "Oh, my god.
Please get us out of here.
Oh, my god.
Please get us out of here."
The Humvee was struck by a rocket
propelled grenade and was thrown
in to the back side of a
disabled tractor trailer truck.
And Jessica Lynch was
seriously injured in that crash.
She did not suffer
gunshot or stab wounds,
but she was badly injured
in that crash.
The "Post" never explained how
it got it wrong, so badly wrong.
It never discussed
who its sources were.
On one occasion one of the
reporters said in an NPR interview,
"Our sources for that story
were not the Pentagon.
They were not military sources.
We could never get
anybody at the Pentagon
to talk about Jessica Lynch."
Which left people wondering, "Okay.
Who could it have been?"
Who could it have been?
Anonymous sources in Washington.
And the town is just full of them.
The point here is to be wary of
stories based on anonymous sources.
Here are a few more suggestions.
Wait. Wait.
I'm not done.
Try to cultivate a little
viewpoint diversity.
Check your biases.
I guess this is a recommendation
that students hear a lot.
Check your biases.
You know, if you're used to reading
the "New York Times," why not pick
up the "Wall Street Journal's"
opinion page every once in a while?
Just to see what else is going on.
Develop a taste for
viewpoint diversity.
And don't be fooled
by satire either.
Don't be fooled by satire.
People are, and it's out there.
And it's plausible, but
really would kind of fit
in to the fake news
definition, I guess.
And some of the best satire
appears in the "New Yorker."
Andy Borowitz is great, and his
satiric column appears periodically.
And this is one example
of Borowitz's satire.
People get fooled by this.
They think it's true because
it's so good, and it's --
You know, it's on the
cusp of plausibility.
On the cusp of plausibility.
So let me just recap.
Remember that early accounts
of disasters often are untrue.
There are errors there.
And to be wary of those.
Hone that ability to
develop the sniff test.
If stories don't seem to be quite
right, you're probably right.
Applying your logic, applying
your experience, saying, "Hmm.
Maybe it's not quite true."
The sniff test.
Be wary of stories based exclusively
or largely on anonymous sources.
This is a real trap for journalists.
They need to do more about this.
This is a toxic equation
many times in which they rely
on anonymous sources, and do
so cavalierly, in my view.
Cultivate viewpoint diversity.
And don't be fooled by
satire in the media.
And to close, another
example from Borowitz.
People believe this.
This one went viral in the immediate
aftermath of the 2016 election.
Again, just plausible enough.
It's just believable enough.
So maybe it was true.
Thank you folks.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 2: [Inaudible]
time for some questions.
>> Joseph Campbell: Questions?
Comments? Yes, sir?
>> Speaker 3: I would take issue
with two things [inaudible]
what you said.
I think in your definition
of fake news in not allowing
for intent then you
don't acknowledge
that news media do make mistakes.
They've always made mistakes.
Out of sometimes carelessness,
sometimes bad sources,
sometimes misinterpretation.
But there's [inaudible] in
there that when they find
out about the mistakes
they correct them.
Which malicious fake news doesn't.
Second point --
>> Joseph Campbell: I
think on that one I --
Let me just answer that
because it's so good.
I would take issue with that.
I don't think the news
media are very good
about making corrections
on big mistakes.
When they get somebody's age
or address, you know hometown,
wrong, they'll quickly do that.
But on a major story that they
screw it up, the tendency is not
to roll it back, not to retract it.
The Jessica Lynch story,
granted it's 12
to 15 years old now,
it's an example.
They never explained.
The "Post" never explained
how it got it so badly wrong.
>> Speaker 2: But other
media corrected it.
>> Joseph Campbell: Not exactly.
We don't know exactly how
the "Post" got it wrong.
We know that she herself later
said that she was no hero,
although she also said,
"I could have taken credit
and no one else would have known."
It would have been
a [inaudible] there,
but nonetheless she never
did say, "I was a hero."
And, you know, she never
acknowledged hero status.
To her credit.
So anyway, I would argue that
news organizations really hate
to roll back major
stories that are wrong.
And we can think of other
examples, perhaps more recent.
The Hurricane Katrina case
is a more recent example.
There was like a one off look
back by many news organizations.
The "New York Times," the "Post,"
the "Philadelphia Inquirer,"
the "Times of London," sort of
took a look back to say, "Okay."
The "Times-Picayune" in New
Orleans, to its credit, as well,
took a look back and said, "Okay.
How did we get this story so wrong?"
The story of mayhem and violence and
Mad Max like mayhem in New Orleans.
And they did a one
off shot about that.
That wasn't really a retraction.
It was just sort of saying, "A
lot of news reports were based
on rumors that were out of hand."
And that was it.
It was a one off.
So yeah. I'm a little
reluctant to embrace that notion
that there is this
corrective mechanism
that news organizations
really like to embrace.
And your second question is?
>> Speaker 2: I think you're
giving short shrift to Woodward
and Bernstein's role in Watergate
that you don't acknowledge the role
that the media did play in revealing
the depth of the corruption
of the Nixon administration.
If the media hadn't kept the heat
on in the summer of '72 and the fall
and so on, we wouldn't have
had congressional committees.
We wouldn't have had
deeper investigation.
So I think you leave the right
impression there when you say,
"Well, the Post didn't
bring down the president."
But the "Post" and other papers
and organizations laid
the groundwork for that.
>> Joseph Campbell: Maybe.
I think you're right.
There were other organizations
reporting the story
in the early days of Watergate.
But the news organizations
were clearly behind the Justice
Department's investigation,
the FBI's investigation.
They never learned
anything from the news media
that they didn't uncover themselves.
This is not to tout the FBI
or the Justice Department,
but they had a pretty good
understanding of the scope
of the scandal well
before the news media.
And sources for the "Post" as well
as other news organizations
were the FBI and the like.
So Sam Ervin who was the chair
of the Senate Select Committee
on Watergate, which held hearings
in the spring and summer of 1973,
identified a number of forces and
factors, including the news media,
but many others as well who
helped prepare the ground
for the hearings of that summer.
So I would argue, and do argue in
my book, that it's a marginal role
that the news media had in
uncovering and keeping the heat
on during the Watergate scandal.
Even if you -- Even if we accept
that the news media were good
in keeping the attention
level up there, it's far --
It's a far cry from saying
that the news media brought
down Richard Nixon.
It's quite a different
interpretation.
Finally on that point, Woodward
and Bernstein themselves have said
in their book that they were kind of
like out of ammunition on Watergate
by the end of October 1972.
And they were talking about
writing a book and so forth,
"All the President's
Men," which they did late
in that year and early in 1973.
So they too were sort of at bay
by the end of October in '72.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Speaker 3: [Inaudible]
their ideas
in getting the biggest headline
the fastest because [inaudible] now
that Trump in Puerto Rico saying
that at least this is not the
catastrophe that Katrina was.
And I think that he's referring
to the narrative of [inaudible].
>> Joseph Campbell:
He may have been.
Look. It's -- You know, the
president is going to, you know,
command -- Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes. I knew I was going
to forget to ask you to --
ask myself to repeat the
question which was related
to the biggest headline and
Trump's visit to Puerto Rico
and linking the hurricane damage
there to Hurricane Katrina.
Did I do justice to your question
or is that just totally butchered?
>> Speaker 3: Well, I [inaudible]
use that one as an illustration
of why various media want to
get a dramatic first statement
of particular events,
and this is one
that we had a recent [inaudible].
>> Joseph Campbell: Sure.
The media's preference
to get a prominent story,
a big headline story, first, yeah.
There's no denying that
the news media are sort
of inherently programmed
that way to get --
To report something major accurately
and in a very, very timely fashion.
And that's one of the
elements that's one
of the fundamentals of
American journalism.
You see it in the long history
of the Associated Press.
The news service that goes
back to the 1850s and continues
to be a thriving source
of news today,
its two imperatives are
to be fast and accurate.
You don't always get both, but
that is what they seek to do.
And then in this age of the digital
world everybody's becoming a wire
service reporter essentially.
All journalists from major
news organizations are posting
to the online sites very quickly.
And very swiftly.
And that's essentially
the AP imperative,
to be fast and first with the news.
And so I think what we're
seeing is this little understood
transformation of American
mainstream journalism
into wire service journalism.
Everybody's becoming a
wire service journalist.
Hope that answers your question.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Speaker 4: I was interested to
hear what you said about journalism
and heroes because I've noticed
the last several disasters
that you see the CNN reporters
or the ABC reporters, whatever,
out there capturing
themselves on tape, you know,
either using their
boat to rescue someone
or help them lift the rubble.
You know? Pass out water and stuff.
And I'm just wondering
what the profession --
the ethics of the profession.
Or what ethics are taught in
journalism schools that sort
of allow you to get so involved
or to use this tragedy
for self promotion.
Is this -- It seems
to be the norm now.
I don't know.
It seems like [inaudible].
>> Joseph Campbell: It's
a really great question.
The question was the ethics
of injecting one's self
in to the coverage of a major
story such as a hurricane
in which you would be using your
own boats or other equipment
to help people or to call attention
to the dimensions of the disaster.
There was a very interesting
"New York Times" article
on this very subject in
the immediate aftermath
of Hurricane Harvey, I believe,
in which they were talking
about the TV reporters who
were standing out in the winds
and the rain and the storms.
It got to be so --
such a cliche anymore
that it's like almost unwatchable.
My wife will watch this stuff, but I
just can't put up with this anymore.
It's just like so routine
and predictable
and doesn't tell you anything.
Okay. We know the winds
are high and there's a lot
of rain, but that's a hurricane.
And it's -- I don't
know why they do it.
I don't think it's a way to
get, you know, new ratings.
In fact, the ethics of it
are a little bit dubious.
One of the touchstones of
American journalism is not
to involve yourself in the news.
I think that that barrier, if
you will, is eroding somewhat.
It's not as hard and fast
as it may have once been.
And I think there's also a historic
tendency for journalists to want
to inject themselves in to the news.
And William Randolph Hearst did it
with his New York journal
back in 1897.
He came up with an approach to news
called the journalism of action,
saying, "We're not just going to
report and comment on the news.
We're going to step in
and make a difference
to the extent that we can."
So we're going to right the wrongs
to the extent that a newspaper can.
And, you know, Hearst was doing
this with some forethought, I think,
because he wanted to become
president of the United States
and used his newspapers as a
stepping stone to the White House.
Never happened, but
nonetheless he came
up with this participatory
journalism, the journalism
of action, that we can see echoes
of today in some of the episodes
and examples that you mentioned.
Journalists coming out there,
you know, rescuing people
on their own and so forth.
And I mean it's -- Look.
A lot of news coverage
is ratings driven.
And this is one way to help
drive the ratings is to --
If you have the dramatic rescue and
the heroic journalist out there.
Absolutely.
There was a question on this side.
Yes?
>> Speaker 5: yeah.
So I'm a folklorist and folklorists
are actually quite interested
in fake news for a
number of reasons.
The American Folklore Society
meeting is in two weeks,
and we have four organized
panels on fake news.
>> Joseph Campbell: Fantastic.
Listen. If you need a
last minute replacement,
I'd be happy to step in.
>> Speaker 5: But the --
So my interest here is that I
find it's true with fake news
that often even though -- Whether
or not you want to include intention
as part of the definition of
fake news, it's often the case
that someone's agenda is being
served by the fake news story,
whether it's the source and
the reporter's just a dupe
or whether it's the reporter.
I mean -- And this is true
both in very specific cases
like [inaudible] Pizza
was aimed at the election,
but also in general cases.
I mean I think that in the case
of New Orleans there's an agenda
of sort of [inaudible] conservatives
to say, "If the police were unable
to help you for five minutes,
everyone would loot
and you'd be murdered."
And there's also an
agenda of rapists
to say black people are
always looting and raping.
And you see this.
You -- All the footage of alleged
rapists and looters were black,
even though those people weren't
really doing what was being claimed.
So I think you can
often find these kinds
of agendas underlying the stories
even if they're not the agendas
of the reporters themselves.
Can you comment on that?
>> Joseph Campbell: Sure.
Comment about the agendas
that may be behind,
lurking behind, fake news.
In the case of New Orleans
post Katrina the agenda --
Some of the most lurid tales
about violence and mayhem
and so forth were coming from the
mayor and the police commissioner,
the most senior authorities
in the city
who journalists would be I guess
excused for thinking that they were
in positions to know what
they're talking about.
I mean it's not like
journalists were following up
and pressing them on, "Okay.
Where did you get this
information, Mister Mayor?"
Because he was saying 10,000
were going to be, you know --
the death toll would be
10,000 in New Orleans,
which would be just staggering.
It was about a tenth or so of
that, but anyway their agenda --
The police commissioner also
was putting out lurid tales
about little babies being raped in
the Superdome and stuff like that.
His reasoning he said later was
that he didn't want to be held --
He didn't want people to think
that he was covering anything up
or withholding information.
Therefore he was pushing everything
that he heard, including rumors
and lurid tales of violence
that were unconfirmed --
just pushing them out in to the
media because he didn't want
to think that people were --
that he could later be
accused of covering things up.
Within a month or so he had lost
his job, and the mayor finally --
Although he was reelected, he
was later indicted and convicted
on corruption charges and
is now a federal prisoner.
Not related to Hurricane Katrina,
but I think sort of speaks
to the quality of public officials
in New Orleans at that time.
So they were pushing
an agenda for sure.
Absolutely.
And I think that there
probably was an unspoken agenda
that the journalists were
pushing too, that we can expect
that this kind of thing would
happen in a largely black city.
There were columnists for the
"Washington Post" who pointed
that out in the immediate aftermath
of the coverage of the lurid
and exaggerated coverage.
And I think they were right.
Absolutely right.
One more question?
Yes, sir? You were very eager.
[ Inaudible ]
How much time do we have?
We could -- This is it?
Okay. Okay.
Make it a good one.
Hardball here.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Joseph Campbell: The
question has to do with fake
or spurious quotations that
run rampant on the internet.
That's for sure.
The internet can be a good way
to debunk if belatedly some
of these lurid and exaggerated tales
and bogus quotations among them.
The Monticello site has also a page
devoted to phony quotes attributed
to Thomas Jefferson, and it is the
first item that if you do a search
for Jefferson quotes, that's
the first return on Google.
Fortunately.
So I guess the algorithms were
working well in that case.
But some of these tales are just
so bizarre that you almost --
So bizarre that maybe they are true.
One of my favorite
Jefferson quotes was --
And you may appreciate this
because of the agenda behind it.
It's that -- Says that
Jefferson in 1781 said,
"Some of my finest
hours have been spent
on my back veranda smoking hemp
and watching as far as I can see."
There is no evidence in his
papers, his letters, his speeches,
his correspondence
which was voluminous,
that he ever smoked hemp.
They made hemp at Monticello
for clothes
and for rope and things like that.
It wasn't really smokable
quality, I don't think.
And he himself was not a
smoker, Monticello says.
There are no accounts of
any of his many visitors
to Monticello ever seeing
Jefferson lighting up.
You know, they grew tobacco
there, but he never smoked it.
He never smoked hemp.
And yet this quotation -- It's
one of my favorites, actually.
Appears to have been born digitally.
It was made up somewhere
early in the digital era,
and has been used as
an example of, "Okay.
If Jefferson smoked hemp, then
why lot legalize marijuana?"
In fact, Gary Johnson, the
libertarian candidate for president,
not this most recent
time, but his -- 2012?
In 2012 he was on a talk show
and invoked this quotation.
Didn't Jefferson say that
he liked to smoke hemp?
And as an example of, okay,
third president and one
of the founding fathers and
author of the "Declaration
of Independence" smoked hemp.
Then it's good enough for us, right?
So there is an agenda behind
that, and it's one of these quotes
that you just find on
Twitter all the time.
There is no, no attempt to knock
it down or to say, "This is bogus."
But it is quite clearly.
And there are many others.
I mean great men and women are
often -- who are deceased are --
Great quotes are put
in to their mouths
and they never ever
said these things.
And Einstein, Benjamin
Franklin, you know, you name it,
George Washington, there are
lots of phony quotes attributed
to these famous people of the past.
And that's one way these famous
quotes or these bogus quotes live
on by attachment to famous people.
>> Speaker 6: One case with
Washington is something
from a newspaper in the '30s
that quoted [inaudible] and then
in the next sentence
editorializing about gun rights,
but those two sentences [inaudible].
>> Joseph Campbell: They
get mashed together,
and then lesser known
people who made a comment,
it sort of gets transferred
to the likes of Lincoln
or Jefferson or Einstein.
I mean they're out there.
There are people who like,
you know, follow this stuff.
And one of the best debunking sites
that I know and I encourage you
to check out is called
Quote Investigator.
And he does a fine job of
debunking bogus quotations.
And he has a presence on Twitter.
It's social media, and it's
refreshing to see that kind
of debunking done of
bogus spurious quotes.
>> Speaker 7: [Inaudible] bring this
discussion to an end unfortunately,
but let's thank Joe one more time.
>> Joseph Campbell: Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thanks, everybody.
A great audience.
Thank you for your fine questions.
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.